-This is familiar.
I like this seat.
-Yeah, you do.
The last time you were here,
it was after your final game.
-Yeah.
-Do you remember
when you were here?
You remember what was happening?
-It's a little foggy.
-Yeah, because you were --
-I had a hangover.
-Yeah.
-I had my first hangover.
-Exactly right.
-But I was wondering
once I left,
why was there a nurse right
there in the room when I --
I'll just leave that alone.
I never been somewhere where
they had a nurse right away.
-Yeah, we took care of you, man.
-I was like, "I got a hangover."
The nurse came out of nowhere.
-Because you don't drink, right?
You're an athlete.
-Well, yeah, I drink.
-You drink,
yeah, but not that much.
-No, I drink a lot.
-You do?
-I have my own wine.
-I know you do now,
but, I mean --
-Well, I never got drunk
like that.
Like, I've always been able to
be, like, cut off.
It's time to go.
But that night, after my
last game of my entire career,
I was, like, to the wall.
-Yeah. You went for it.
And then you were like,
"Jimmy, I hope I'm okay.
I'm sorry if I'm going to be
a little foggy."
You were fantastic.
-I was?
-Yes.
-Don't remember.
-Alright. Good.
Don't have to remember.
Don't worry about it.
You've been very busy in
your retirement, by the way.
You wrote a memoir.
You have fashion brands.
You have a wine, you just said.
And no big deal -- you bought
a piece of an NBA team.
You're part owner of
the Utah Jazz.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
-How -- Couple questions there.
How did you get involved
with Utah Jazz?
And how did that end up being?
-Ryan Smith,
who's the owner of the Jazz,
very good friend of mine
and around the same age --
41 years old.
And, so, playing golf, as well.
We golf together.
Talked about doing
business together one day.
And he one day bought a team
called the Utah Jazz,
flew to my house,
and asked me to be a part of it.
-I love the name Utah Jazz.
Robert, how's the
jazz scene in Utah?
-Does not exist.
-Exactly.
-All-Star Weekend
is in Utah this year.
What's up?
-Oh, I'm down.
-Talk to me.
-Oh, yeah, you know Robert.
-You know what I'm saying?
-I'll bring jazz to Utah.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Let's do it.
-That's the way it works.
-Let's do it.
-Yeah.
-Does it get frustrating
for you, as an owner of a team,
to watch the players,
and you're like,
"I don't know
if I can watch them."
Because you know how to do it.
-Yeah, see? It's hard.
-It is, right?
-It's hard watching
a game period.
-Yeah, cause you want to
get in there and go,
"No, I'll show you how to do it.
You do this and then that
and then this."
-Because all
you're thinking about is
what you would do, right?
Like, you hoop a lot,
as I've heard.
-Yes.
-Right?
Do you think about what you
would do when you watch the NBA?
-Well, I think,
"Wow, I'd like to do that."
Are y'all rebuilding?
-We're reshaping.
-Yeah, reshaping.
-We don't use "rebuild"
in the NBA.
-Nice terminology.
-Reshaping.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, I like that.
You've played basketball,
pickup, with some of
the biggest celebrities around.
I have a picture of you
playing with Adam Sandler.
How's Adam's game?
-Adam's nice.
So, that was 2006, the day after
I won my first championship.
-No big deal.
-No big deal. Thank you.
And I got the chance to spend
some time with him in the back,
and he told me that,
at the time,
they called him
"The White Dwyane Wade,"
because I was really known for
my backboard shots around
that time.
I would come down
and shoot off the glass.
And Adam got a little
two-hand backboard shot.
And so they was calling him
The White D-Wade.
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
-I've got to ask him about that.
How about this?
With President Obama.
You played a pickup game
with President Obama.
How is his game, first of all?
-Yeah.
So, legendary. Legendary.
-It is, right?
-I played a pickup game
with President Obama
on his 49th birthday.
It was, like, a cryptic e-mail
that came through.
I didn't really know
if I was, like --
if I was just showing up
and then somebody
was playing a trick on me
or was it actually,
like, president's birthday
and we were going to hoop.
-At The White House.
All it said was,
"Show up to The White House
and bring your sneakers."
And I was like, "I'm going."
I don't know who this is from,
but I'm showing up.
But -- He's actually --
He's not bad.
-Really?
-He's a lefty.
He has a real --
As smooth as he is,
that's how smooth his game is.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-How's Trump's game?
-Who?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
-He said, "Who?" He said, "Who?"
-Didn't get that e-mail, huh?
-No, I didn't get that one.
-Yeah.
-So, we're scrimmaging with
President Obama,
and he brings us all in
and he'd say,
"Hey, I want you guys
to play hard
and play like
this is a real game."
And then
we looked around the court,
and there's Secret Service
all around the court.
And it's like,
"We can't touch you."
-We can't play a real game.
What are you talking about?
-We can't foul you for real.
-Imagine if you did that?
-No, Joakim Noah did.
-He did?
-Oh, he picked him up
full court,
was elbowing him,
and everything.
It was great.
-As you should.
-That's why he
never got invited back.
-Yo, you would [bleep] Biden.
-Alright, alright.
Let's not get any ideas.
That's not going to go down.
We actually...
[ Laughter ]
Joe, do not invite --
I don't want to see this happen.
Please.
There's another player
I'd like to get your take on.
I'm curious if you think
he's any good.
He played in the NBA Celebrity
Game earlier this year.
We have a clip.
Take a look at this guy.
-You know what it is, guys?
I was just --
-Uh-oh.
-Back again.
-Make the extra pass.
-Oh!
-Where'd that guy come from?
-So, initially --
Let me see this shot.
-What are you seeing out of
Jack Harlow here?
-I see him turning --
-Shawn Marion influence.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Shawn Marion?
That's what I was thinking.
-What were you thinking?
-Shawn Marion.
He shoots like --
Shout-out to Shawn Marion.
-From, like, the pelvis --
-Yeah.
You shoot like the ball was hot.
Like, he laid it up like it was
like a hot plate in his hand.
He was like...
-Well, sometimes,
that's when the lights are on.
You know, your form
changes under pressure.
But it's been
restructured since.
-It's been restructured?
-Yeah.
-It went in. It looks --
-Did you like the clips?
What did you think of the clips?
-It looks terrible.
-Oh.
But it's effective.
-You're lucky we don't have your
highlights up here.
-Well, I mean, I wish you did.
I'm play them for my son
all the time and like,
"Look at your dad."
-Yeah, watch what dad -- Yeah.
Let's talk about
"The Redeem Team."
-Yes, sir.
-Congrats on this.
Thanks for doing this,
executive-producing this.
But explain to people
if they don't know what
"The Redeem Team" was, can you?
-Yes. So, 2004,
the Olympics in Athens, Greece,
which it was a tough time
in the world around that time.
A lot of the stars players
in the NBA
were opting out of playing
in the Olympics
because of war things going on
in the world.
And so they called on
the younger guys --
myself, Carmelo, LeBron --
to join this team.
And we joined this team with
Allen Iverson, Tim Duncan,
Stephon Marbury,
and all these great,
you know, NBA players.
And, so, we were like, "Cool.
We're about to go win us
a gold medal."
And that didn't happen.
We won the bronze.
We were pretty terrible
as a team.
-Worst summer of my life, bro.
-Yeah, it was...
-Worst summer of his life.
It really bummed him out.
But, I mean, that was -- Yeah.
-Well, I mean, I think,
at the time, we realized, one,
that the world,
like, was not catching up --
they had caught up, right?
We were playing
against teams that had been
playing together since
they were 16 years old,
maybe even younger.
And so the chemistry that
they had we did not have.
We got together two weeks before
in Jacksonville.
-And you're own stars
in your own rights,
so you're like, "I don't really
know how to play as a team
with these guys,
'cause --" Yeah.
-And then, it's the rules.
It's FIBA rules.
It's a FIBA game.
You got to learn
how to play their game.
It's not the NBA game.
The rules are different.
And, so, the ball is different.
Everything is different.
And, so, we got together,
and, like, it was --
The practice was a tragedy.
-It was just --
-It was a separation between
teams, too.
Like, it was just
a thrown-together team.
And, so,
to get to the Redeem Team,
enter Coach K from Duke,
enter Jerry Colangelo.
And they decided to
build a team.
And, so, we spent the next
three summers in Vegas.
We had a great time.
-Yeah, yeah.
I could imagine, yeah.
-We spent the
next three summers in Vegas
building, like, chemistry
and building continuity
and building the team.
-How was Coach K?
-Coach K is awesome.
-Yeah, he's just cool, right?
-He's just cool.
And I didn't know he
said [bleep] so many times.
Can I say that on TV?
It was great.
-Yeah, it was great.
-He's like, "These..."
I was like, "Yes,
I'm ready to go play."
-Really? Yeah.
I went to go see him coach once,
and he was just yelling.
He was pointing
at some clipboards like...
[ Shouting indistinctly ]
And they lost the game.
And then, at the end, they go,
"Do we want to go back
and say hi to Coach?"
I go, "No. I don't ever
want to see that guy.
He scares me. He frightens me."
-That was him at like --
So, our games was at 9:00 p.m.
We were in China in 2008.
And that was him at 9:00 a.m. at
walk-through and shoot-around.
He was fired up and ready to go.
-Yeah. But all of you guys were.
-Yeah, well,
after losing, we had --
It's called the Redeem Team.
We had to redeem ourselves.
-And you got the gold.
-Yeah, we got the gold.
-That's the way to do it.
Gold medal.
-Yes, sir.
-And it's fun to have
the bronze, too.
-Yeah. So, I thought --
We thought it was a great time
to be able to tell this story.
Obviously, our brother,
"Kob," is not here,
but to have his presence and his
voice in this documentary,
to have "Bron's" presence
and "Melo's" presence
and Coach K, like, all
the voices to tell this story.
And this was pre-Instagram.
This was right when Twitter
probably popped off.
No one really knows about
the Redeem Team and, you know,
what all came about
to get to that place.
So I think they're
going to be surprised,
and it's a
pretty good documentary.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is a clip from
"The Redeem Team."
Take a look.
-Well, first half was disjointed
because of foul trouble.
Now there were more minutes,
and people were
playing different roles.
-They bring in Dwyane Wade
and Deron Williams
a little earlier than expected.
-Sometimes, you feel like
you've been there before,
you've done this before.
Like, I knew I was
going to have a big game.
And when I got in,
I got right to it.
-Wade to the basket.
Goes inside.
Beautiful move.
There's Wade with the steal.
-Not only did I get two fouls
early, Kobe did, too.
And that set the stage
for D-Wade.
-Yeah, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's the way you do it
right there.
Dwyane Wade, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Redeem Team" begins
streaming on Netflix tomorrow.
We'll be right back with
a performance from
Quavo and Takeoff.
Stick around, everybody.